[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag dernier
numéro de notre spécial élections
municipales ce qui vous préoccupe
particulièrement pour ce scrutin c'est
aussi l'augmentation de l'insécurité
dans certaines villes de france les
candidats de tous bords promettent dans
leurs programmes de renforcer les
effectifs policiers pour en débattre sur
ce plateau nous sommes avec alexandre
langlois policiers et président du
syndicat vigie face à vous georges
kuzmanovic présidents de républiques
souveraines
jérôme pierrât journaliste spécialiste
en en crime organisé et en grand
banditisme ainsi que nadir caillat
président de banlieue plus merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
le nombre de cas de violences sexuelles
d'homicides ou de coups et blessures a
nettement augmenté l'an dernier pour
lutter contre la délinquance
christophe castaner veut mener le combat
de l'international à la cage d'escalier
le chef de l'état lui s'est rendu à
mulhouse il ya deux semaines pour
promouvoir les brigades de reconquête
républicaine
vous voyez ce reportage en région
parisienne de solenn gaudin dounia syrie
cynthia lauvergeon et laurent pas les
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
un dispositif mis en place en 2010 8 à
l'initiative de gérard collomb alors
ministre de l'intérieur
objectif majeur lutter contre les
trafics en particulier de stupéfiants
mais aussi recréer le contact entre la
population et les forces de l'ordre et
les partenariats avec les élus locaux
en ile de france 14 sites ont été
désignés pour recevoir des effectifs et
des moyens supplémentaires
problème les renforts se font toujours
attendre
nous avons le contenant mais le contenu
nous nous sommes toujours en banque
lexique l'ancien préfet de police de
1500 agents les faux pas au mieux
non plus les services judiciaires parce
que quand vous interpellé une personne
c'est très bien vous l'interpeller quand
elle comme un délit mais ensuite vous
avez les procédures à traiter et nous
avons un manque cruel mais vraiment
terrible d'officier de police judiciaire
à paris pour cela nous avons alerté les
autorités et comme prémisse de
l'intérieur mais pour ça il faut une
volonté politique et un dispositif qui
ne convainc pas les associations de
prévention de la délinquance réconquérir
ça veut dire qu'on est en conflit ou un
truc qu'on veut on n'a pas à reconquérir
normalement c'est notre territoire la
république a toujours été dans les
quartiers c'est lé maire quelle que soit
leur étiquette politique à droite ou
gauche qui ont entre guillemets pour moi
n'ont pas respecté la république alors
comment voulez-vous dire aux jeunes de
respecter les lois de la république
si ces mêmes élus qui nous représente ne
respecte pas sur le terrain on a laissé
tellement tellement les choses à pourrir
un certain nombre et aussi la politique
des grands frères que sarkozy nous a mis
en place on a retiré la police de
proximité elle tout ça on a retiré les
contrats du ltte relais qu'avec kaïré
été mis en place à l'éducation nationale
on a retiré énormément de probes de
contrat et on a favorisé certaines
associations qui sont sur le terrain qui
sont pour l'utiliser avant tout et qui
ne sont pas vraiment dans la présence de
prévention mais sont plus dans une
idéologie dans une victimisation des
politiques infructueuses d'autant que
les chiffres de la délinquance flambe en
ile de france
rien qu'à paris selon les statistiques
de la préfecture
les vols à la tire ont augmenté de près
de 32% en 2019 et on viens de l'entendre
dans ce reportage nadia rehman a dit on
a laissé les choses pourrir nadi callas
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
constat en ile de france et d'ailleurs
ailleurs en france en précisant avoir là
car alors oui je suis je suis
globalement d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit notamment aussi de la part du
policier juste avant sur un terme qui
est assez important mais qui est très
court qui paraît comme ça peut-être pas
intéressant pour les auditeurs mais
quand on dit qu'il n'ya pas de volonté
politique ça résume tout vous avez beau
essayer de faire un travail de terrain
qui pour certaines personnes comme nous
dans le domaine associatif est tout à
fait naturel parce que on vit dans ces
quartiers on aspire à mieux vivre et
donc la combattre un peu certaine
fatalité ou certaines réalités
mais il y a malheureusement un jeu
politique qui existe depuis toujours en
france et notamment dans les villes
dites populaires qui nous aident pas à
régler ses problèmes parce que ce
géopolitique et malsain c'est un jeu de
guerre du ch et à la souris aussi
également avec certains hommes
politiques le fameux clientélisme
il ya aussi cette situation qui est réel
dans nos quartiers qui nous aident pas à
régler ses problèmes qui perdurent là on
parle d'un abord mais ça fait trente ou
quarante ans qui a exactement des
rapports comme ça avec des chiffres qui
monte qui descend qui devait répéter
qu'ils peuvent être contestées mais
globalement je pense qu'il n'y a pas une
réelle prise de conscience de la part
des autorités et des langues volonté
politique pour vous il laisse pourrir
les choses aillent mieux
mais en partie oui alexandre l'on doit
on va parler des chiffres justement de
ce dernier rapport sur la délinquance ou
vraiment il ya une hausse quasiment dans
tous les dans tous les domaines
concernant cette violence ces chiffres
là comment est ce qu'il sait ce qu'ils
sont fiables
est-ce que et un commentaire d'ailleurs
de votre part en tant que policier sont
fiables non non et c'est là que c'est
encore plus dramatique c'est que ça
arrive même plus à cacher la poussière
sous le tapis sur marseille à des
collègues il ya deux ans de deux ans oui
c'est ça vous avez donné les éléments de
langage pour diminuer les chiffres de la
délinquance une volonté politique de ne
pas trop à paraître alarmiste là dessus
bah c'est une volonté c'est depuis la
politique du chiffre de monsieur sarkozy
les chefs de service vous déprime s'ils
ont des bons résultats donc du coup ça
redescend en cascade ça arrange le
gouvernement d'avoir des bons chiffres
comme celle peuvent nous dire droit dans
les yeux
tout va bien et il faut pas moins je
pense qu'ils doivent être pire parce
qu'en fait quand il ya des tentatives de
cambriolage avec effraction s'est
qualifié en dégradation volontaire quand
il ya des vols à l'arraché c'est des
vols avec violence s'est requalifiée en
vol simple
donc non prise en compte des victimes
une des collègues qui ne se retrouvent
pas dans leur travail et les seuls qui
sont autant c'est ce qu'ils touchent des
primes
je vais donner l'anecdote c'était
l'année dernière sur les chiffres de la
délinquance à marseille ce que cela que
les collègues vous avez donné les
éléments le directeur départemental
préfet annonce très fièrement les
chiffres de la délinquance ont encore
baissé pour g6 première année
consécutive c'est magnifique on va avoir
des chiffres négatifs et le lendemain je
rappelle tout le monde doit se souvenir
il y avait des règlements de comptes à
la kalachnikov dans la cité donc ça veut
dire que la réalité n'est pas du tout
les chiffres qui sont là il faut venir
vivre sur place et par exemple donné les
termes de reconquête républicaine
c'est ridicule parce qu'on est en train
de dire on a focalisé de 30 quartier on
va encore faire 30 l'année prochaine
c'est dire qu'à l'heure où la république
a dit on a abandonné 30 quartier qui
sont plus chez nous mais c'est
complètement aberrant
donc soyons sérieux il faut juste donner
des moyens politiques aux policiers
pourraient intervenir sur place on met
en nombre suffisant et surtout des
policiers qui ont le recul et
l'expérience de la vie si on envoie les
plus jeunes comme dans l'éducation
nationale
et ils vont pas réagir pareil à 20 ans à
30 ou 40 ans donc c'est une volonté
politique d'organiser cette insécurité
est en tout cas ce sentiment ce que la
réalité des fois plus complexe que cette
carte de chiffres aseptisé on va parler
du sentiment d'insécurité qui n'est pas
forcément
celui de la hausse de l'insécurité
véritablement georges kiejman au beach
ces chiffres vous inquiètez est ce que
la politique menée par le gouvernement
est satisfaisante selon vous pour lutter
contre l'insécurité avec la mise en
place de ces zones de répliques de
reconquête républicaine par si vous le
permettez je vais le prendre de manière
plus large
je considère qu'on est dans un système
d'impunité généralisée et ça commence
par l'eau avec la criminalité en col
blanc nacré unité politique
on est quand même dans un pays où il est
quasiment impossible de mettre un
politique qui a massivement fraude est
derrière les barreaux où il est
impossible de trouver quelqu'un qui va
frauder des millions et des millions au
fisc qui va prendre de l'argent qui
devrait payer à l'impôt et ça ça crée
pas de sentiment d'insécurité en soi non
mais ça crée un sentiment d'impunité et
il devient très difficile de de punir ou
de jeter leurs regards sur des
populations où effectivement il peut y
avoir une criminalité et visiblement en
hausse en ayant un tel laxisme vis-à-vis
de ceux qui nous dirigent
or la situation elle est telle qu'elle
est c'était plus simple quand on avait
un général de gaulle qui est un peu
exagéré mais paient c'est sur facture de
l'électricité ce qu'ils considéraient
qu'il avait payé en trop par rapport à
son occupation de l'elysée bon bah quand
on a quelqu'un comme ça qui dirige le
pays on peut avoir une de quelqu'un qui
dit bah c'est pas bien la criminalité
mais quand on a des gens tels que ceux
que l'on a actuellement au pouvoir
tu as un rapport plus que plus que
proches avec la finance internationale
c'est celle aux mauvaises herbes mais
regardons effectivement par le petit
bout par en bas là où c'est le plus
difficile dans la société il ya
effectivement une hausse de la
criminalité et qui affecte en premier
lieu les catégories et les plus
populaires parce que la criminalité il
me semble qu'elle tape le plus c'est là
où les gens ont le plus de difficultés
sociales et économiques
ce n'est pas pour justifier les crimes
valider ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
dans des conditions difficiles qu'il
faut pas être sanctionné mais on a un
problème général de non financement de
la police de la justice de l'ensemble
des services de la république parce que
ceux-là même qui sont au pouvoir et qui
seront plutôt tranquille par rapport à
leur propre
exactions je pense à monsieur guéant par
exemple un qui se financer son
appartement dans l'arc de triomphe par
visiter ce soir je suis là il très bien
parce que pendant dix ans ils étaient
mises l'intérieur soit il est très
intéressant
pendant dix ans elle a réussi à sortir
800 euros de son compte en banque en
dépenses personnelles disant 800 euros
c'est à dire ça veut dire qu'on a un
niveau de sentiment d'impunité qui est
absolu et total
or ces gens-là appelé politique voulue
par l'union européenne néolibérale qui
font que les services publics ne sont
pas financés en particulier ceux de la
police qu'il manque des policiers aient
vent que des effectifs il manque de
moyens donc faut pas s'étonner que comme
en arrive là où on en est on à dire
qu'il ya parlé de manque de moyens hors
là est la seine-saint-denis est quand
même un département qui qui a beaucoup
de demandes de subventions service est
paradoxale
ce français c'est un des départements
les plus riches de france 3 que ce avec
le deuxième troisième
mais paradoxalement sa population est
l'une des plus pauvres donc là on voit
que politiquement il n'y a pas un
investissement il n'ya pas une volonté
de réinjecter la richesse qui est
produite dans ce département ce que
j'appellerais qui est des aéroports et
des zones d'activités une population
hyper dynamique et d'entrepreneuriat il
ya énormément de choses qui sont propres
aux quartiers populaires et aux
banlieues il ya un dynamisme qui est là
une effervescence qui est là mais
bizarrement on ramène des problèmes aux
problèmes
au sein de l'association ont fait des
maraudes bon je change un petit peu le
jeu change un peu le la lunette mais
vous voyez un petit peu là où se
concentrent les migrants les sdf
ils sont deux portes clichy jusqu'à la
porte de vincennes dont ils encerclent
un peu le 93 ils sont au début du 93 on
concentre bizarrement depuis des années
depuis presque toujours une misère dans
le 93 et comme j'ai dit alors qu'il ya
un préfet se rajoutent des problèmes au
problème c'est ce que tout à fait mais
et ça et ça c'est bon on va pas rentrer
dans plus dans la théorie du complot du
complotisme mais les politiques ne sont
pas aveugles
il ya des réalités dans 93 qui sont qui
sont visibles aujourd'hui et notamment
par rapport à la délinquance et la
violence
elles existent certes mais elles
existent aussi ailleurs mais bizarrement
on se focalise sur le 93 des
départements ou des villes dites
populaires et on fait croire à la france
entière que la violence que
les incivilités sont concentrées dans
les quartiers alors que ça parce que tu
as fait envers le top 5 des villes les
plus dangereuses considère en tout cas
comme les plus dangereuses de france
alors il ya évidemment un saint denis
marseille on a cité en deuxième puis je
suis sous bois et montfermeil paris
19ème arrondissement de la capitale et
sarcelles et garges-lès-gonesse jérôme
pierrât cette criminalité aujourd'hui
est elle semblable à ce qu'on a appelé
le grand banditisme et la criminalité en
général est ce que c'est les choses ont
évolué selon idc sa bile feuilles la
criminalité à la victime andy rhis que
ça revêt ce parce que le le le sentiment
d'insécurité généralement il n'est pas
tellement liés au grand banditisme
voilà le grand british attaquer un
fourgon blindé mais les choses sont
allées en ont effectivement là là le
banditisme qui est issu des quartiers
populaires qui compte dont on entend
parler depuis quelques années ses terres
il est très lié au trafic de stupéfiants
donc ils impactent directement à son
plus bas niveau
parce qu'en fait quand on parle du
trafic de stups les quartiers c'est le
récit port d'hyères on sait le dernier
maillon de la chaîne commerciale
peut-être par les jets remonter assez
loin donc tout ça pour ça mais tout ça
pour dire on va je vais citer christophe
castaner on va l'écouter d'ailleurs le
ministre de l'intérieur il disait il
veut en tout cas faire de la lutte
contre la délinquance
l'une des priorités de son mandat et il
dit il faut lutter de la cage d'escalier
jusqu'à l'international écoutez le elle
était ce que je souhaite c'est pas qu'on
fasse de l'interpellation ou du volume
justement de produits interpellé mais
qu'on puisse mener l enquête sur la
globalité de la chaîne ses airs de
l'international jusqu'à la cage
d'escalier voilà donc pas forcément
faire du chiffre en nombre mais
s'attaquer vraiment à la base du
problème
ça sert à rien d pouget la mère du
trafic à petit niveau avec une cuillère
est ce assez
il faut remonter jusqu'à la source il ya
des pompes d'approvisionnement dans des
pays producteurs et des filières qui
sont plus on monte dans le trafic plus
réduire les intervenants plus vous
montre cette scène pyramide c'est la
logique du commerce dont calade ses
rêves dans les correspondances zones où
il ya de la délinquance aujourd'hui en
france ou pas oui bah globalement on n'a
pas regardé oui
sèye les grands centres urbains de toute
façon ça alors ce qui est assez étonnant
c'est que en termes dans les chiffres
notamment qu'augmenter il ya des
règlements de compte et les homicides +
10 % ou 9% je crois il ya une forte
hausse qui est due au règlement de
compte justement dans les quartiers qui
sont liées aux os différent au trafic de
stups
alors ça effectivement ça en explosion
et le phénomène nouveau corner c'est que
dans le temps
allah sait que dans le temps on avait
une queue d'une délinquance qui
s'entretuaient qui étaient concentrées
sur un axe en gros à paris lyon
marseille dans les grands centres
urbains
c'est là où on appelait le milieu le
grand banditisme aujourd'hui le
phénomène qu'on a ça a commencé comme ça
dans les quartiers plutôt l'île de
france marseille etc
et puis on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que ce
assez atomisé ta vous avez des villes
comme car montferrand vous avez là
montpellier la semaine dernière qui
maintenant connaissent des règlements de
comptes violent à la kalachnikov alarmes
automatiques et c'est ce qu'on retrouve
dans les quartiers nord dont on nous
parle dans le 93 depuis longtemps là
donc ça c'est un phénomène nouveau en
revanche espèce de d'atomisation mais
qui regarde quoi concrètement
bah c'est à dire que en gros c'est ça
suit l'atomisation du trafic si vous
voulez avant c'était le trafic il était
en étoile il y avait des grosses équipes
de malfaiteurs étaient concentrés dans
quelques points du territoire
là où il y avait des bassins commerciaux
en résumé quand vous vendez de la drogue
faut des clients donc c'est généralement
pas tellement aux zones rurales
désertique c'est plutôt là où il ya une
population donc avant s'étaient
concentrées là dedans on s'aperçoit que
maintenant le trafic de stups y gagnent
des quartiers populaires dans des
agglomérations un peu moindre de moindre
importance et donc les méthodes suite
c'est à dire les différends commerciaux
qui sont liées à ces trafics la dca
trafic vous allez alors si vous derrière
les règlements de compte les embrouilles
voilà les meurtres et compagnie
alexandre langlois 70% du du crime
organisé est lié au trafic de
stupéfiants qui est le terreau de toutes
les délinquances ni christophe castaner
il a raison sûr qu'il ya une bonne
partie puisque c'est là où il ya
beaucoup d'argent qui est en jeu pour
une fois je vais dire que j'ai encore
avec mon ministre que fawcett a souligné
mais après la halle comment ça c'est le
trafic de stups s'est transformé avant
il y avait le grand banditisme qui
tenaient les grandes villes
effectivement comme ça a été dit mais tu
en sais plus des clans qui tiennent des
quartiers et c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
règlements de compte c'est pu essayer
des clans qui se battent pour des petits
morceaux de trafic plus d'unité de
trafic et ce qui fait que maintenant
c'est visible avant qu'un grand
banditisme tenait veille avait aucun
problème
d'ailleurs même c'était ça qui était
paradoxal je repense aux émeutes qui ont
eu villiers-le-bel et en 2005 dans les
endroits où il y avait du grand
banditisme qui tenait certains quartiers
ils ont dit le premier qui bouge
nous on vient vous tapez donc parce que
nous on veut pas qu'on vienne nous
déranger dans notre business
donc en fait c'est le monde à l'envers
en fait à l'heure actuelle et après pour
lutter contre ce qui se passe monsieur
castadère par exemple a mis en place un
numéro spécial de lutte anti drogue
voilà avec un nouvel office mais quand
on fait le compte il a dit il ya plus de
policiers à l'intérieur mans il ya moins
de douaniers donc en fait on perd des
effectifs et on sait où sont les trafics
de drogue je prends un exemple dans le
morbihan à vannes les riverains ont dû
passer des petites annonces sur dix on
cherche des guetteurs parce que la
police n'y a pas faire son travail
donc au bout d'un moment ça devient
impossible on sait où sont les points de
deal la deuxième chose également c'est
que les pouvoirs publics sont des fois
hypocrite on a des collègues qui avaient
travaillé sur un réseau qui avaient
démantelé le réseau ça c'était bien
c'était à quelques années les records
dont en matière de trafic de drogue
selon le gouvernement pardon année
record en matière de trafic de drogue
le gouvernement se félicite ddd forte
saisie de de drogue cette année en tout
cas la vraie question c'est pas la
saisie qu'on fait c'est qu'elle est le
trafic général parce que s'il y a créé 6
à + 10 % mais qui est le trafic a
explosé de 200 500 en fait on n'en sait
rien donc une fois de plus monsieur
castagnède il veut pas il veut pas
raisonner en chiffres il me raisonne en
chiffres il veut a ragé de la cage
d'escalier au trafic international me
donne pas les moyens de le faire donc au
bout d'un moment il faudrait mieux qui
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il
démissionne parce qu'il n'est pas à sa
place mais voilà faut laisser des
professionnels travaillent sur le sujet
et démantèle les services de police à
chaque fois qu'ils apprennent dans la
police nationale depuis le début du
quinquennat avec monsieur castaner est
en poste
il crée un numéro de téléphone violences
faites aux femmes numéro de téléphone
drogue numéro de téléphone c'est ce
suicides numéro de téléphone donc en
fait au bout d'un moment on a besoin
d'avoir des gens sur le terrain on a des
centres d'appels
donc il faut être un petit peu sérieux
la police n'est pas un centre d'appels
su travail d'investigation de terrain et
d'aller au contact des gens et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que reproche la population
c'est qu'ils ne voient plus j'étais dans
certains quartiers populeux dire
regardez ça fait deux heures qu'on
discute dehors on n'a pas vu un policier
on a plus que des poésies qui sont rayés
faire du saute dessus 10 à 20 ans ou 30
ans en arrière on avait des gens qu'on
connaissait c'était nos policiers donc
si on veut réseau le résorber le trafic
il faut envoyer des gens au contact pour
avoir les bonnes informations qu'on
pouvait la création de l'eau faste ce
fameux l'office qui est censé régler les
problèmes et n'est pas suffisant ça ne
change rien en fait celle collègues de
la pj nous ont dit
à partir de maintenant ce sera comme
d'habitude on a changé les logos ça
coûte une fortune parce que pour faire
toutes les feuilles et un nouveau numéro
de téléphone alors que tout bêtement
avant il y avait un numéro de téléphone
unique c'était le 17 je les lots fait
c'est pour harmoniser un peu toutes les
polices renseignement police de terrain
etc avant une meilleure coordination
alors je ne sais pas il paraît qu'on a
un directeur général de la police il
paraît qu'il ya déjà les gir qui sont
les groupements inter régionaux qui
travaille sur les rentes transversale
donc en fait on a rajouté un
millefeuille avec des nouvelles
effectifs avec des nous donc on fait on
est dans l'habillage le cosmétique pour
les gens qui ne savent pas ce qui se
passe mais en tant que professionnel de
la police les collègues qui travaillent
concrètement sur le sujet ils ont dit ça
ne change rien à part que l'argent qui
va être servi pour refaire les logos on
aurait préféré de l'avoir envoyé un
concrets pour l'anc est georges
kuzmanovic la réponse sécuritaire la
réponse policière est elle suffisante
selon vous et et est-ce que ça manque
pour résoudre notamment tu n'es pas bien
évidemment que ce n'est pas suffisant il
ya une réponse à court terme moyen terme
et à long terme
à long terme c'est le retour d'un public
c'est l'éducation est la principale
disent on va renforcer nos effectifs de
police municipaux etc pour lutter contre
toutes sortes d'incivilité ou de
délinquance donc encore à ceux qui
seront élus s'ils le feront et puis
quels moyens ils vont donner alors alors
policiers mais bon par an plus tôt la
police nationale par rapport à ces
problèmes de délinquance il ya le long
terme hanks et c'est l'éducation c'est
le respect des valeurs de la république
quel moyen terme c'est un grand maître
du boulot en france
enfin peut pas fonctionner comme un pays
où on a en réalité officiellement 8 5%
de chômage et et 20 % de travailleurs
précaires
enfin la conséquence ne peut être que
mauvaise en terme de délinquance
donc il faut du travail il faut que la
société se réorganise et puis à court
terme évidemment fait une répression
policière
mais elle peut pas être juste un bis il
est le thème que j'ai utilisées c'est du
saute du soc dessus bon qui voilà c'est
fait du chiffre mais ça règle rien à
long terme et je vous avez suivi
plusieurs fois dans ce que vous avez dit
c'est des enquêtes de long terme pour
démanteler des réseaux qui rend beaucoup
plus d'effets et plus avoir une police
de proximité ce que semble vouloir
certains candidats dans certaines villes
avec laure police
municipal maintenant moi j'habite à
paris
j'ai été surpris mais la police
municipale à paris c'est pareil faut il
faut quand même qu'on ne voit pas
souvent
moi je les ai vus récemment j'ai vu une
fois elle encadrait des parents qui
étaient pas contents de traitement qui
avait été fait par rapport aux écoles
avaient après le nuage de plomb ou que
des parents qu'il n'est pas très très
content par rapport à l' agence de santé
régional par rapport aux représentants
de la mairie de paris
ils m'ont les voit très peu du côté de
prendre la chapelle où toute façon ils
ont aucun moyen vu que voilà déjà un peu
pour la pour la police nationale nadir
khayat et régis du bérange aujourd'hui
c'est que ce genre de débat c'est des
débats qui existe depuis des années mais
on a parlé tout à l'heure de volonté
politique mais au-delà de ça je pense
que les français doivent comprendre que
si on veut vivre mieux en france
on doit aussi s'impliquer certes
aujourd'hui c'est les municipales c'est
l'occasion de voter mais on peut pas
simplement voter et croire qu'un homme
providentiel va venir régler les
problèmes on sait que la politique a son
importance mais les citoyens aussi ont
leur leur jeu leur rôle à jouer dans les
quartiers et moi je rappellerai que
simplement monsieur valls en son temps
en 2016 avait dit qu'il existe un
apartheid social territorial ethnique en
france donc ce constat il l'a fait on
fait tous ce constat notamment quand on
est issu des quartiers populaires qui
est des inégalités un problème de
discrimination problèmes de violences
policières des réalités concernant la
délinquance on est d'accord là dessus on
fait tous les constats je crois qu'on
est le pays des rapports en france tous
les ministères sont remplies de rapport
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui manque c'est
des hommes avec la volonté de travailler
avec les personnes qui sont issus du
terrain pour trouver des options des
solutions et les solutions elles ne sont
pas que répressive
il faut aussi voir l'aspect éducatif on
a parlé aussi l'éducation du logement de
la citoyenneté un mieux vivre ensemble
tout à fait on vit déjà ensemble on vit
parfois difficile difficilement par
rapport aux on a parlé du chômage des
réalités qui touche tous les français
qui sont pas propres quartiers
populaires mais aujourd'hui au delà de
ça il faut dépasser le l'aspect
répressif où l'on fait croire aux
français qu'on va venir avec des
nouvelles mesures pour taper un peu plus
sur les banlieues parce que c'est aussi
dans l'inconscient c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne on parle d'insécurité donc
c'est les banlieues les banlieues ça va
pas les banlieues c'est les jeunes les
jeunes sont tous des délinquants donc à
partir de là on va mettre plus de
policiers tout en sachant que la police
elle-même n'a pas les moyens de faire
son travail
le monsieur l'a dit donc c'est vrai que
les politiques doivent prendre
conscience de cette réalité mais les
citoyens français doivent les mettre au
pied du mur par rapport à ces réalités
qui sont persistantes
et ils le réclament d'ailleurs une
remarque sur le stade et hausse des
chiffres de la criminalité
on peut se demander dans quelle mesure
la surutilisation des forces de police
pour réprimer de manière délirante même
sa vache à lait de la mobilisation et
les gels et jaune avec une répression
qu'il a été franchement de leurs deux
tontons macoutes
encore une fois douze mille arrestations
3000 condamnation d abord 2000 qui
finissent en prison
les voilà tous les dizaines de blessés
graves
on peut se demander si utiliser toutes
les formes de police y compris
administratives ou les bacs
bon les armes en les mettant des
situations où ne sont pas entraînés à
faire de la très mauvaise opération
contre des manifestants n'hésitez pas à
la hausse devait être mais ça c'est sur
paris uniquement après le prime et sur
paris uniquement fin comme ça à la fin
il n'y a pas eu le temps a réuni grandes
villes on avait ce ridicule de milliers
milliers policiers mobilisés et en même
temps le porte parole du gouvernement ou
la porte parole qui disait on voit pas
tellement de gilet jaune ils sont plus
que 2010 est parfaitement ridicule donc
annuler sûrement contribué à ce que il
ya une hausse de la criminalité manque
de la présence policière en tout cas
dans ces moments là où ils font des
manifestations de la luminosité est
assez récurrent inclus 10e aussi de
répartition des forces de l'ordre vous
allez dans les beaux quartiers de paris
vous avez je sais pas le nombre de
policiers au mètre carré que vous vous
n'avez pas retrouvé dans les quartiers
ou dans les villes dites populaires donc
là aussi
oui mais là aussi les disparités qui
font qu'aujourd'hui
le propos de monsieur castetner ou des
politiques à ce niveau là pour des gens
comme nous qui sommes sur le terrain
c'est un propos comme comme un autre
comme il en existe depuis toujours en
france ont surtout que là c'est les
municipales donc on va faire croire aux
français qu'on va apporter la sécurité
qu'on va faire des choses mais le
monsieur l'a dit les policiers ne sont
pas entendus même si à notre niveau on
peut être critique sur certaines
interventions de la police
on arrive à concéder à comprendre et à
voir que les policiers n'ont pas les
moyens de de faire leur travail donc à
partir de là je pense qu'il faut
entendre tout le monde et il faut
vraiment se mettre autour de la table
aujourd'hui une bonne fois pour toutes
pour travailler avec les différents
partis et les personnes qui sont motivés
pour régler enfin ou essayer de diminuer
la criminalité la délinquance et de
retrouver ou alors de d'apporter une
france ce n est un peu plus équilibré
alexandre langlois très court il nous
reste très peu de temps six mois c'est
vraiment un manque de moyens pour lutter
contre la criminalité et la délinquance
en tout cas pour établir un sentiment de
sécurité en france et un manque de
moyens manque de moyens ou en partie oui
alors de formation également à manque de
aussi répartition selon les tranches
d'âge des policiers et une volonté de
toujours
quoi qu'en dise monsieur k ster de faire
du chiffre du chiffre pour pouvoir
briller dans les médias je veux donner
un exemple très concret avait une
brigade qui faisaient beaucoup de
chiffres dans une ville qui a mené sans
affaire donc c'était sans boulette de
shit
il avait les félicitations régulièrement
et toutes les primes et une autre
brigade elle qui allait prendre son café
au café du coin pour discuter avec les
gens ils ont dit et puis un moment le
caf qui leur dit mais il ya des gens de
l'autre brigade qui sont venus me voir
en disant qu'il y avait des policiers en
uniforme qui prenaient leur café je vous
ai couvert les gars ils ont au contraire
au contraire voir dirait qu'on prend le
café nous avec vous on le paye
s'ils veulent prendre la température du
quartier de savoir ce qui s'y passera
devant les associations les gardiens
d'immeubles discuter avec les gens et
les gens leur donne notre numéro de
portable personnel pour qu'ils nous
appellent parce qu'on ya un lien de
confiance et après quand il ya quelque
chose with you gonna donc du meilleur
enseignement semer du renseignement et
surtout de la confiance parce que les
gens ils appellent ils disent j'ai tel
sentiment j'ai vu ça mais vous allez
voir débat voilà ce que vous avez vu
c'est ça ils sont rassurés il s'était
rien passé s'était fait un film sur
quelque chose de complètement inexistant
et en averse qu'on avait quelque chose
il n'intervenait plutôt qu'un numéro
standard 17 ou faut attendre trois
plombes à la préfecture de police de
paris c'est un numéro surtaxé
je veux dire on du quotidien avec de
l'être humain au centre de la population
mais temps c'est impensable qu'un
policier y faire ses courses soi à boire
un café en uniforme mais c'est à ce
moment là qu'on voit les gens qu'on
discute c'est là qu'on voit que les
policiers sont des êtres humains
derrière l'uniforme c'est là qu'on fait
du contact et que les gens dans 90% des
cas veulent vivre
qu'il ment donc ils vont parler aux
policiers pour dire j'ai vu ça et nous
on fait notre travail derrière pour
vérifier si oui ou non il ya quelque
chose on va durer dans les années 80
raconte huile et on en parlait justement
rester avec nous on continue ce débat
sur l'augmentation de l'insécurité en
france
c'est un des enjeux des municipales à
venir on en parle dans quelques minutes
restez avec nous a tout de suite
[Musique]
l'arrivée de la série g est ce qu'on
peut parler de révolution
techniquement oui on peut parler de
révolution est ce qu'on pourrait pas
réservé sa à des applications bien
précise plutôt que vouloir absolument le
mettre à disposition de tout le monde il
faut avoir en tête pour que pour chaque
génération il faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée des kills à l'appliquer chez
ça veut dire développer une application
qui fait le boom est ce que on a bien
mesuré toute la dépense énergétique de
nouveaux terminaux de nouvelle
implantation de relais le futur de la
cinq cdc des systèmes de communication à
très très très haut débit enfin
télécharger un film plus vite
qu'est ce que ça va vous apporter les
craintes et c'est parce qu'il ya un
manque d'information est probablement un
manque de collaboration est ce que
aujourd'hui le monde entier a besoin de
la saint jean
le football est richissime et le
football génère beaucoup d'argent donc
génère beaucoup de redistribution pour
les footballeurs des principaux sportif
et donc leur rémunération
mais à côté tous les sportifs et
l'immense majorité des sportifs de haut
niveau qui participent aux jeux
olympiques et participe à des
championnats du monde gagne très mal
leurs vies ne sont absolument pas la
compagnie ne sont pas aidés ne sont pas
soutenues et résultats comme vous l'avez
dit 4 sur 10 gagnent moins de 500 euros
par mois donc je pense qu'il faudrait
réfléchir sur un dispositif vraiment
plus spécifique puisque le monde du
sport c'est une spécificité n'ont
peut-être tenté de rentrer de rentrer
dans sa pour pouvoir mieux accompagner
les sportifs de haut niveau est
considérée l'espoir un peu amateur comme
vous l'avez si bien dit l appétit sme ou
d'autres sports comme un métier on parle
de jeu pour le sport on parle de loisirs
de pratique de loisirs vraiment
d'amusement et de métier contraignant de
pénibilité pour le travail et ont donc
il serait logique d'accorder des aides
et destruction pour les travailleurs est
illogique de faire de même pour les
sportifs puisque il s'amuse
[Musique]
mais tous
les vagues la suite avec alexandre
langlois policiers et président du
syndicat vigie georges kiejman au beach
présidents de républiques souveraines
jérôme pierrât journaliste spécialiste
en crime organisé et en grand banditisme
ainsi que nadir khayat président de
banlieue plus c'est une étude qui est
passée plutôt inaperçue dans les médias
en décembre dernier celle de
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
et pour cause puisqu'elle révèle que les
violences sont en hausse depuis quatre
ans avec une augmentation significative
l'an dernier mais sam shemie si l'on se
réfère aux données du service
statistique du ministère de l'intérieur
aucune région de l'hexagone est épargné
par ce fléau notamment ce qui concerne
les agressions et les harcèlements
sexuels 54 1100 fait enregistré sur
l'année 2019 dont 22 1900 simplement
pour viol autres chiffres alarmants du
ministère de l'intérieur celui du nombre
des homicides qui a gagné + 8 5% par
rapport à 2018 soit 970 victime de plus
alors que le nombre semblait s'être
stabilisée ces dernières années ce
rapport révèle une explosion 2019 d'une
autre catégorie de délinquance celle sur
la voie publique
caractérisé par des dégradations de
biens publics d'agressions de vols à la
tire ou encore deux cambriolages des
chiffres particulièrement inquiétant à
paris l'an dernier il ya eu plus 12,1
pour cent d'atteintes aux biens publics
+ 32 % de vols à la tire plus 42 5 % de
vols dans le métro
enfin + 6 % de cambriolages dans les
sociétés et entreprises
enfin les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur et révèle une augmentation
importante des escroqueries sur
l'ensemble du territoire
+ 11 % qu'il s'agisse d'agressions
sexuelles de vol d'homicide ou encore
d'escroquerie aucune région du
territoire ne semble avoir été épargné
par cette hausse de la délinquance
voilà une hausse de la délinquance que
l'on constate généraliser partout en
france
jérôme pierrât est ce qu'il ya une
hausse de la criminalité classique celle
du
grand banditisme ou pas est-ce que les
deux courbes sont parallèles noël s'ils
sont plutôt pas le trafic de stups ci
explose les règlements de compte ayant
explosé
donc la tendance à la hausse oui le
chiffre qui est notable c'est des
cambriolages ya beaucoup d' équipe de
malfaiteurs qui viennent nord de l'est
depuis quelques années ils sont
spécialisés dans les cambriolages en
série par centaine doivent mais
globalement la glagla grande criminalité
normes ce elle change de spécialité mais
finalement le volume global rsa peut
mais mais de toute façon elle se résume
à 80% ou 75 ou 90 n'ont pas porté au
trafic de stupéfiants
on va écouter laurent nunez et xavier
bertrand qui lie cet insurgé de chez de
ces chiffres d'où la médiatisation de ce
rapport écoutez la passe d'armes entre
les deux hommes le chéneau nièce comme
monsieur castaner ces messieurs tout va
bien tout va bien dans le pays
il n'y a pas de problème d'insécurité ya
pas de problèmes de délinquance est ce
qu'ils connaissent ces chiffres là il
ferait bien de regarder les stats les
chiffres il y avait 2 174 mille victimes
de vols violences
en 2010 nous sommes tombés à 166 mille
en 2018 et sans nous avons encore
baisser cette année
voilà donc on voit c'est une guerre de
chiffres alexandre langlois comment
comment comment rétablir les choses et
parler
vrai en fait sur sur cette insécurité
déjà ce qui est assez ridicule et assez
blessant ces cas ils sont en train de
faire une guerre des chiffres
ça vient c'est pas du tout de savoir
comment les victimes sont accompagnés
comment les gens sont mal voilà une
explosion par exemple des violences
agressions sexuelles etc bascule
phénomène mis tous les genres en plus
parler c'est pas parce que ça casse'
séparatif c'est plus de déclarations de
gens qui viennent de déposer plainte qui
osent pas celle pas parce qu'on a essayé
de les mettre en confiance derrière il
ya plus la formation n'y a rien eu mais
des gens qui cogne fait l'effort de
venir donc ça fait augmenter les
chiffres mais ce qui me fait de la peine
ces conditions sur une bataille de
chiffres alors que c'est on parle
d'êtres humains qui sont victimes de
gens qui commettent des crimes et des
délits ou faudrait les moyens qu'on
aille les chercher et on s'en fiche de
savoir si on a plus ou moins en fait on
voudrait qu'il n'est plus et qu'on
interpelle les personnes et sur la
hausse de la délinquance je fais un
petit trait d'humour c'est qu'on a le
gouvernement et les élus
on n'a jamais eu de temps de mise en
examen était toujours au poste est aux
commandes de suspicion de diverses
fraudes variées et différentes
c'est la première fois qu'on a un
président qui a lui mis à son programme
de dire qu'il n'avait pas de casier juin
vous de voter un casier judiciaire
vierge pour les élus l'assemblée
nationale dit non on va garder un cadre
judiciaire au cas où donc je vous dirais
le par halak seulement dans cette
histoire le seul ministre va le seul
politique de la réplique en marche qui a
démissionné de son poste et benjamin
griveaux qu'il eut été victime
finalement pénalement il a rien fait de
répréhensible après les tickets tout ça
on peut en parler mais pénalement il
était victime
et finalement ce gouvernement les
auteurs d'infractions ou soupçonnés
reste en place
ça c'est ce qu'on lui disait la
recherche mais laïque et on à la sphère
benalla pour montrer un exemple si temps
quand l'exemplarité vient pas d'en haut
après on peut faire une bataille de
chiffres pour le surinam tout le monde
mais ce monsieur rien tout le monde
venait accompagner et veulent un accueil
humain au commissariat on fait des prêts
plateau ling pour déshumaniser
on fait tout pour écarter les policiers
les commissariats ferme en mettant les
gens doivent des foires faire une heure
de route pour aller au commissariat
je veux dire soyons sérieux non voilà
faut remettre de l'être humain
et puis leur bataille de chiffres ça
montre bien que bas ils sont dans des
stades dans un autre monde mais pas le
monde réel
il ya aussi une image des policiers qui
s'est considérablement dégradée est ce
que ça est-ce que ça influe justement
sur le comportement finalement 2
des citoyens qui peuvent donner dans la
délinquance ou si à cause de ça j'en ch
l'usma nourriture on l'a vu on s'en
prend à des voitures de policiers dans
certains dans certains quartiers ça
aussi c'est un phénomène qui
n'apparaissait pas il ya quelques années
parce que monsieur langlois on parlerait
mieux mais il me semble qu'une partie
des agressions les attaques qui sont
faits contre les véhicules de police et
les policiers sont liées plus tôt à ces
petits à ces clans à ses protégés trafic
dans la vrai changement comme de mootwin
depuis quelques années les délinquants
jamais dit qu'ils étaient très amis avec
la police c'est pas la question
il hésitait quand même à aller à
l'affrontement direct
il ya maintenant une sorte qu'ils
évitaient il avait un peu plus peut-être
là l'idée que la sanction derrière on se
disant donc ils sortent ils sortaient
les arbres où il répondait compte
vraiment ils étaient coincés la sortie
de la banque et clive un an de prison se
profiler mais si nos et ans a levé les
mains quand même à limiter les dégâts au
change rien
aujourd'hui il ya une logique
d'affrontement on représente plus l'état
où la république on reprend une bande
adverse
on est plus ou moins fort voilà donc si
elle vient empiéter bas on va attaquer
que c'était donc on n'est plus dans une
défense du délinquant par rapport aux
policiers mais on est quasiment né on
est presque dans certains cas une
agression enfin je veux dire à une
agression préventif d'ailleurs on va et
cd loger les policiers du quartier pour
pas qu'ils s'installent pour déroger bah
oui on voit aussi une peur qui
s'installe la peur change de camp entre
guillemets mais on a un peu l'impression
quand même c'est ça qui est peut-être le
plus inquiétant si la police a peur qui
va nous porter je pense que quand même
une dans les premières dans le premier
acte c'est assez flagrant la tentative
de rapprochement entre entre les
manifestants spontanée qui n'étaient en
général ni les militants d'ultragauche
l'ultra droite il même rarement des gens
qui avaient fait de la politique
nombre de cas où il venait et
rejoignez-nous vous gagner autant vous
et des problèmes existent aux ensembles
on voyait les deux premiers actes des
policiers et des gendarmes qui étaient
un peu ballot avec des petites dames ou
des messieurs bon après tout ce qui
j'ai suivi avec tous les tous les
blessés et tous les ans franchement
qu'ils agissaient comme des milices
habillé on n'est pas très bien que c'est
des policiers c'est sûr qu'au bout de 18
mois de ce régime à un couteau et blessé
ça n'a pas dû être terrible pour si la
vision on les sent bien et toujours
battu en disant qu'ils avaient deux
visions de la puce qui s'opposaient en
mai 68 en caricaturant lui avait préféré
grimaud qu'avec faux policiers en disant
ne frappez pas un manifestant à terre il
calmait les ardeurs des policiers
maintenant on avait un préfet l'allemand
et les policiers sur le terrain a essayé
de faire au mieux pour exécuter des
ordres le moins bien qu'ils peuvent
médiapart façon à ce que me dit rien on
donnait des ordres on l'annonçait depuis
déjà un moment on avait vu avec à
bordeaux comment il a géré la ville de
bordeaux avec coup il a couvert quand
même les policiers qui avaient tiré dans
le dos d'olivier behzad le pompier deux
tiers de l bd dans le dos un tir de
grenade à côté de la tête et ils
l'interpellent pas il n'emmène pas se
soigner
quatre fautes professionnelles et
couverte ou sa part le préfet l'allemand
qui avait dit à l'époque l'abord à
bordeaux tout s'est bien passé c'est
parce qu'il y avait le chaos et on
regarde les images voilà ce qui pose le
deuxième problème c'est que c'est le
monde qui a fini l'enquète avant les gps
qui l'a sélectionné pour paris donc
c'est la sélectionner pour paris est
donc là mediapart vient de sortir un
dossier où hier en disant voilà le
préfet l'allemand dix ans les offres qui
sont donnés sont illégaux il ya eu une
résistance au niveau des crs des
gendarmes nous c'est ce qu'on dit depuis
longtemps donc ils ont pu sortir des
preuves c'est parfait donc ça montre
bien une volonté politique de répression
et cette volonté est incomprise par les
policiers qui voudrait être le week-end
se reposer je vais donner pour résumer
un petit peu il ya cité sur au mois de
mars de l'année dernière il ya un
collègue qui avait pas vu qu'on monsieur
edouard philippe avait fait son discours
de politique sur tf1 et il y avait pas
regardé en disant mais qu'est ce qu'il a
annoncé pour que tout le monde retourne
chez soi en fait une solution politique
un problème politique
il a dit on va taper plus fort le
week-end prochain est un fait mais ça
c'est pas une réponse pratique ça ça
veut dire que j'ai encore pas voir ma
famille je vais faire des heures
supplémentaires
on a déjà le terrorisme à gérer on a
déjà le travail quotidien gérer les
effectifs baissent parce qu'en fait le
concours le recrutement ne se fait pas à
taux plein malgré une baisse du niveau
du concours
donc je veux dire les heures
supplémentaires sont pas payés ou alors
au rabais donc en fait il ya tout est
organisé pour que ça se passe mal et et
nadir callas est
vision du policier dans certains
quartiers s'est dégradée selon vous bah
c'est quoi c'est compliqué parce que les
français ont découvert les violences
policières avec les premiers
manifestation des gilet jaune c'est les
policiers qui ont peur nos malo non
malheureusement dans les classes
populaires la violence populaire la
violence des policiers et d'une certaine
catégorie de policiers
moi je veux pas globaliser ou
généralisée elle existe depuis toujours
je rappellerai kylie kylie a
régulièrement on avait affaire adama
traoré régulièrement depuis 30 ou 40 ans
d des jeunes et des moins jeunes qui
sont issus des quartiers populaires qui
sont violentés par une minorité de
prévert c'est vrai aussi
oui mais là c'est souvent des gens qui
n'ont rien à se reprocher ou même si
c'est des choses des personnes qui
avaient des choses à se reprocher les
circonstances de leur mort ou dans leur
violence ne justifie pas ce qui s'est
passé donc dans les quartiers on connaît
la violence policière et c'est pour ça
qu'une partie moi même quand j'étais
jeune j'avais une image assez négatif
des policiers parce que on a été
contrôlé on a été insulté et violenté
tout en n'ayant rien à me reprocher j'ai
rappelé avec notre association et le
collectif stop contrôles au faciès
on a fait condamner l'état pour les
violences policières en 2016 en
cassation c'était une première
donc la justice a reconnu qu'il y avait
des contrôles au faciès abusif et ça on
le dénonce depuis toujours
moi le premier je suis pour qu'on donne
les moyens à la police de faire son
travail correctement là où il faut comme
il faut ça sous prétexte que la police
ait respecté justement dans ces énoncés
elle est respectée comme partout en
france dès l'instant où elle fait son
travail correctement
je rappelle quand il ya des violences ou
des problèmes de délinquance dans les
quartiers les premières victimes ce sont
les habitants des quartiers populaires
et les habitants des quartiers
populaires comme n'importe quel français
aspirent à vivre bien et quand on
parlait tout à l'heure de délinquance ou
des chiffres au delà de chercher
absolument à faire de la répression ou
faire croire aux français qu'on apprend
un peu plus dans les quartiers on allait
résoudre les problèmes c'est se mentir
aujourd'hui dans les quartiers
populaires certes certains ont une image
assez négatif négative des policiers par
rapport à ses agissements mais
globalement comme en france on respecte
la police quand a fait son travail
correctement on a besoin de la police
quand il ya des problématiques qui sont
réels mais on aspire quand elle réprime
la police elle est forcément dans
l'examen de leur ai pris dans le cadre
de la loi il ya pas de problème à ce qui
va rester
iron a quant à elle réprime dans le
cadre de la loi il n'y a pas de
problèmes surtout quand c'est des
personnes qui le justifie par rapport à
dédaigner la délinquance des actes
violents n'y a pas de preuve mais quand
tu as fait pas son travail et que là
aussi on parlait tout à l'heure de
représentativité ou d'exemplarité par
rapport aux élites la police c'est
pareil ils vous avez des policiers qui
se comportent comme des cow boys depuis
longtemps on a parlé d'un amas traoré y
en a d'autres
depuis des années qu'ils sont morts ou
ont été blessés et malheureusement la
justice et complices dans certains cas
parce qu'elle ne rend pas justice aux
parents vous avez encore des parents là
on suit des familles qui sont qui
aspirent à voir la justice pour les
enfants qui sont morts depuis 10 15 ans
qui n'ont toujours pas la justice parce
que la justice parce que la police ne
suis pas la justice ne suit pas pardon
parce que la justice travailler tous les
jours avec la police qui sont pas
capables de dissocier un policier qui
fait son travail correctement d'un
policier qui est un délinquant
simplement il est en uniforme et qui n'a
pas procédé à une intervention ou une
interpellation correctement et ça ça
crée de la suspicion sacré phénomène
isolé c'est pas isolé c'est pas isolé
parce que ça dure depuis toujours donc
ça fait 40 ans que ça dure simplement
les chiffres sont peut-être faible par
rapport à d'autres de cinq ans mais il
ya une délinquance en col bleu qui
existent dans les quartiers et qui n'est
pas condamnée comme il faut depuis des
années ce qui fait qu'il ya une partie
des gens qui habitent dans le quartier
qui ont peur de la police ou qui ne
souhaite pas on a vu que
la sphère de clichy sous bois c'est une
bonne à qui on est et qui se sont sauvés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été contrôlés moi
même quand j'étais jeune on éviter les
contrôles de police parce que certains
policiers agissaient anormalement
insultait mettait de la pression ou
taper certaines personnes et ça
malheureusement ça rajoute un peu de la
méfiance la suspicion vis-à-vis de la
police dans les quartiers
il faut absolument une police qui soient
équipés qui soient formées qu'ils soient
armés comme il le faut aussi dans
certains cas mais il faut aussi une
police exemplaire comme nos hommes
politiques
et si on n'a pas ça malheureusement ça
va rajouter un problème au problème il
ya deux choses injustes pour adama
traoré c'était la gendarmerie qui sont
régis par le code militaire qui ne
pensent que c'est pas les mêmes règles
d'intervention donc c'est pour ça qu'à
chaque fois on veut nous mettre sur le
dos rond the way mais ça est le même le
respect mais ce n'est pas la même a dit
attendre toujours la justice mais oui
mais je veux dire c'est police en a déjà
assez à faire pour la police il est très
fier de justice voilà la deuxième chose
c'est sur le prêt n'est pas réglée en
fait tout simplement pour deux choses 1
c'est que l'inspection générale de la
police nationale c'est la police enquête
sur la police on est quasiment une
exception en europe
dire qu'en fait la police la haute
hiérarchie politique a cité est mise en
doute un gps et pas qu'il ait mis en
doute c'est qu'en fait c'est très clair
on a eu un cas très flagrant avec la
sphère steve à nantes
kan s'est dit jpm quand kate c'est
circulez ya rien à voir le dossier du
crs qui est spécialiste du matin l'or
dont le met au fin fond de la nex et
quand c'est la policière soul enquête
d'un juge
du coup là c'est rien va bien donc on
voit bien que c'est une institution une
institution qu'elle a pour blanchir les
au directeur je rappelle qu'à des
directeurs conte puis volé dans la
caisse dans les frais qu'on peut tuer
une personne en état d'ivresse et n'ont
rien eu alors que quand un cuistot en
crs lui il s'est pris trois mois tu es
administration a demandé trois mois de
suspension pour un repli de 4,5 périmés
donc en fait en fonction d'eux on est
positionné dans la police dgpn blanchi
plus ou moins ensuite sur la deuxième
chose sur les quartiers donc déjà s'ils
avaient ce contrôle on aurait des choses
en moins la deuxième chose aussi il faut
que les gens qui arrivent dans des
quartiers populaires d'un exemple parce
que c'est arrivé récemment et bien
quartiers populaires
à mantes-la-jolie là ce qui se passe est
d'habitude c'est au mois d'octobre deux
derniers sont tombés mais quand ils sont
tombés dans une embuscade
voilà dans une dans un guet-apens la
tradition habituel c'est eh ben on
revient et on tire des grenades dans
tout le quartier et on tire dans le tas
le commissaire a dit ban on va pas faire
comme ça il a dit ce que vous avez vu
qu'il sait qui vous êtes tiré dessus
ben non qu'est ce que ça vous faire
demain je vais voir le procureur qui
avait appelé temps de tirs de grenade 0
interpellation mais vous êtes sérieux ou
quoi ben non donc il a dit on va vers
autre chose on va faire une enquête
on va chercher les gens qui ont
réellement fait ça au final avec une
enquête les choses poussées ils ont
retrouvé quatre personnes qui ont été
condamnées compris de la prison ferme
est finalement qu on fait un travail
pédagogique auprès des policiers qui
disait bad habituons va riposter et
c'est un travail de fond qui le font
mais ça c'est qu'à une décision
politique c'est une position au niveau
de la comment gères la police si tous
les commissaires spézet ce boulot là bas
les policiers seraient contents parce
que les gens qui les ont réellement
agressé sont condamnés par la justice
les gens dans le quartier serait content
parce que ces gens là qui sont autour
n'aurait pas à subir ça va il est
dommage collatéral y compris les
agissements voilà donc en fait ce serait
quelque chose de naturel et
spectaculaire peut-être aussi pour aller
médian de pouvoir une réponse adéquate
aussi épais sinon on arrive à des
situations comme bas par exemple à
chanteloup-les-vignes qu est l inverse
les certains policiers n'ayant pas faute
d'encadrement ce mois je pense qu'une
part de responsabilité sur le policier
terrain mais après l'encadrement doit
aussi recadrer les choses ou bouddha
mentir je vois pas les plus jeunes dans
les quartiers les plus compliqués une
formation voilà deux formations du même
d'expérience de la vie
on réagit pas vraiment de la table on en
a pas on n'est pas la même réaction à 20
ans 30 ans 40 ou 50 ans et on a beaucoup
de par exemple de gens qui étaient même
d'une des policiers là-bas en fait métis
mettait à mal dans un comportement non
professionnel et personnes les arcades
ont envoyé en formation
du coup les habitants du quartier
prenait fait et cause pour les
délinquants disant ben en fait ils ont
peut-être raison de résister
al'inverse aussi la délinquance et à
voir aussi dans l'autre sens et que je
dis ça parce qu'en fait c'est une
expérience de la vie tu sais on a des
délinquants qu'on connaît très bien qu'à
20 ans sont dans le trafic de stups sont
vraiment à tout faire il ya 30 ans quand
ils deviennent pères mères de famille
mais du coup là ça change le discours il
se range ils cherchent un travail plus
mode est donc en fait l'expérience
d'avis et pour tout le monde
après la police en fait après on nous
prend pour la poubelle du pays dire
qu'on doit gérer l'épreuve des
situations les problèmes sociaux les
problèmes de chômage et en fait on pense
qu'on a la réponse est le couteau suisse
à tous nous notre travail réel c'est de
s'occuper les infractions au code pénal
et pas eux mêmes non monsieur l'allemand
le préfet de police à vaughan ou
rajouter un nouveau délit le délit
d'opinion en parlant de candy fait
alors que nous on a les cours de gens
qui respectent le code pénal et les
autres s'ils n'ont en fait pas là on va
dans des dérives très graves
donc voilà qu'on nous laisse faire notre
travail sur le code pénal le judiciaire
et qu on nous rajoute pas des choses à
côté ça c'est un problème généralisé de
déliquescence de la république et de
l'état
les enseignants aussi se retrouvent jeux
restaient les mêmes l'aller les
abaissant le blick
au lieu d'enseigner mathématiques ou
l'histoire règle les problèmes sociaux
font des garderies les pompiers c'est
pareil il faut jamais jurer sur 7 sur
les chiffres qu'il y ait un chiffre qui
est intéressant c'est le 11 %
d'escroquerie en plus je vous annonce
que pour cette année là qui vient le
chef va être de plus au moins plus 100%
parce qu'avec la réforme des retraites
et retoquées par le conseil d'état c'est
pas énorme mais c'est intéressant que
c'est une forme d'escroquerie quand même
s'est généralisé c'est pour la blague
par contre il ya un chiffre est terrible
c'est celui de la hausse des violences
sexuelles
oui et ferment aujourd'hui c'est la
journée internationale des droits de la
femme et un pour cent des violeurs sont
en prison est important donc le chiffre
c'est 22 1900 mais en fait les chiffons
entre 200 à 500 viols en fonction de ce
que disent les associations de ces
problèmes de défense de la chaîne j'ai
dit des femmes violées il ya plusieurs
cas c'est quand même 70 milles 6 un
chiffre bas c'est 70 mille par an le
commissariat déjà mes plats mais on
arrive au bon là tout un tas de
problèmes d'éducation il ya une impunité
là qui est peut-être une des plus
ahurissante dans la socialiste les
criminels savent qu'ils peuvent violer
une femme un pour cent de chances de
faire se faire choper est allé en prison
je vais donner les gars et je vois venir
a également juste que vous avez dit cela
il y avait quand même ici un problème
parfois de laxisme vis-à-vis de certains
petits criminels les plus forts ce qui
est policier deviennent un peu zinzin de
voir des jeunes qui sortent autant il
sort ensuite ils vous répondent pas en
prison où la justice est pas au rendez
vous et bon vous avez attrapé dix fois à
mon randonnée il ya des fois il tourne
mal et là encore c'est un défaut de
financement de république
un défaut j'ai géré on va parler du cas
de marseille
le banditisme que l'on connaît ces
échanges de coups de feu il ya eu dix
morts déjà alors qu'il y en avait 12
l'an dernier les maires les brigades des
mères elle va pas forcément les regards
des mères mais les maires prennent les
devants et demande au gouvernement par
exemple d'allouer tout l'argent des
saisies que cet argent aille dans les
associations c'est ce que font par
exemple les italiens pour lutter contre
la mafia
comment il ya déjà toute façon une
saisie effectivement de l'argent du
matériel
iliad agences qui ont charge des saisies
qui chaque année augmente augmente
augmente son but c'est censé être
distribués donc c'est un local pour
lutter contre l'alors la gagne en italie
c'est assez bien encadré et les biens de
la mafia qui sont confisqués x ordonnée
mais afin d'exploitation etc
c'est souvent des projets économiques
assez pas je prends la villa et puis je
vais la donner
on saisit d'entreprise on leur redonne à
une association qui veulent agir et que
c'était là bas pour l'instant ça ça
n'existe pas en france il faudrait
identifier les bonnes sensations les
bons projets problème ces classes et
quand on saisit du numéraire du liquide
on se voit mal prendre la valise et 10
rebonds mais vous la donner à
l'association en fin de rencontre se
battre elle agit en tout cas oui bah les
maires ça fait longtemps qu'il manifeste
à marseille face au nombre de règlements
de comptes délire au combat en irak
alors dix ans mais c'est un ensemble
alors on va revenir sur ce qu'on disait
c'est à dire qu'il était impossible
d'endiguer le trafic de drogue en
envoyant juste quatre policiers dans les
quartiers très serré ils vont par deux
êtres fantomatiques l'ailé là là là là
bas qui ont faim de façon quand vous
voyez les effectifs en place dans les
quartiers nord vous avez deux équipages
au mieux de police qui peut retrouver
dans une zone définie d'un bien ça et
puis depuis a plus rien installer
emparés de leurs armes et si on parlait
de la guerre lui qui avait abandonné
alors moi je sors rapidement mon sujet
parce que je travaille jusque sur la
criminalité très organisé de mai on le
constate quand on a dans ces quartiers
là il ya ya ya plus rien il ya une
certaine déliquescence de tours
d'éducation de l'encadrement de la
police qui n'est plus tous présents dans
les quartiers nord à marseille à 30 ans
il y avait des commissariats dans les
cités maintenant ça n'existe plus et
plus dont il y avait un lien il y avait
une forme d'autorité que tu est
respectée connu surtout depuis le début
aujourd'hui cdc des zones totalement
quasi désertique doux que voilà donc
pour l'instant non il n'y a pas vraiment
de moyen on le voit bien la police avait
le terrain depuis des années à marseille
ça n'a pas fait baisser le nombre de
règlements de comptes ce qui est sans
doute le plus inquiétant c'est que les
règlements de compte ils sont quand même
assez élucider ce qu'on oublie dira
c'est souvent du mal à un règlement de
compte augmenter mais la police
travaille bien parce qu'il ya 50% des
règlements de compte marseille qui ont
été élucidés afrique et plus flippant
c'est que c'est l'ensemble antichi pas
parler trivialement c'est que ça
nordique pas le phénomène cercle les
jeunes ont beau face à ça c'est à dire
je vais quand même choisir cette voie
qui est quand même à peu près sans issue
puisque la moyenne des morts enfin là je
dois être de 22 23 ans donc c'est aussi
ça qui est inquiétant c'est à dire que
y'a vous êtes face à une jeunesse
aujourd'hui une espèce de génération
perdue qui malgré les balles malgré la
répression parce que les passes et
erratique de drogue se sont durcies
quand même hein on est pas si sûr des
peines à deux chiffres quand même là où
des gens prenait 5 4 3 2 ans maintenant
des sur des cases en 12 ans 10 ans
hector d'autres comme des peines très
lourdes
donc on voit que ça de dissuader
personnes de toute façon il ya une telle
masse d'argent en jeu et c'est donc si
je peux me permettre je sais pas si
c'est un mot de la fin mais ce que je
voudrais dire pour que le gouvernement y
les autorités comprennent une chose au
delà de l'aspect répressif c'est qu'on a
besoin d'exemplarité dans les quartiers
aujourd'hui on est dans une culture de
la violence on voit à travers les médias
vous avez des chaînes spécialisées qui
vous montrent de façon récurrente de la
violence de la délinquance ond favorise
aussi un rap parce que les jeunes et
dans les quartiers dits populaires ont
lancé cette culture urbaine mais aussi
ont priviligié vous voyez des radios ou
des chaînes qui met aussi un rap violent
avec un discours violent au sein de
l'association et un peu partout vous
avez des gens qui insistent et qui se
battent et qui frappent aux portes des
médias aux portes de certains ministères
pour leur fort contre leur faire
comprendre qu'il faut aussi passer par
l'image
on a besoin de l'image on a besoin d'une
image positive et qui passe tout
simplement à mettre en exergue ce qui
existe dans les quartiers et ça aussi ça
pourrait permettre d'aider la jeunesse
et les moins jeunes à comprendre qu'il
n'ya pas de fatalité qu'on est pas
obligé de passer par un cursus de
violence pour réussir mais ça les
politiques ne comprennent toujours pas
et aujourd'hui ils ont le discours
malheureusement qui est malsain
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique et des
français c'est de faire croire qu'on va
venir avec plus de policiers tape le
plus fort plus fort et qu'on va régler
les problèmes et c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va les régler il faut absolument
mettre tous autour de la table que ce
soit l'éducation nationale la santé le
logement les associations qui sont sur
le terrain
les politiques et les bonnes volontés
les experts comme il ya autour de la
table pour vraiment travailler de façon
globale et trouver des solutions
concrètes
et durable on va passer à notre sondage
en ligne et on a posé la question ce
soir à nos téléspectateurs d'arte et
france et sur nos réseaux sociaux vous
sentez vous en sécurité dans votre ville
la réponse est oui à 43% non à 57 % donc
c'est à peu près équilibré 1 français
sur 2 en moyenne
voilà pour ce débat merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de venir témoigner sur
ce plateau
c'est la fin de deux pôles it mag restez
avec nous pas de politique mag la
semaine prochaine ni la semaine suivante
pour raison d'élections municipales on
se retrouve le vendredi 27 mars avec nos
contributeurs
restez avec nous
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable de nos
soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant locaux
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité